- [Voiceover] A college
bookstore charges $60
for a yearly membership.
The first book is free
with the membership,
and any book after that
costs $7.60 including tax.
How much money, m, does a student spend
after buying b books
and a yearly membership?
So m, the amount of money
that they're going to spend,
it's going to be the yearly membership,
which is $60.
So we're gonna do everything in dollars.
$60, plus the amount
that they spend on books.
So they're gonna buy b
books at $7.60 per book.
So it might be tempting to say all right,
I'm gonna do $7.60 per book,
and then multiply that times b books.
So this right over here
might be very tempting.
We have to remember something.
The first book is free.
So if you buy one book,
you're not going to pay $7.60.
You're gonna pay nothing.
If buy two books,
you're not going to pay $14.20,
you're only going to pay $7.60.
So you're only going to pay for one less
than the number of books you buy.
So instead of $7.60 being
times the number of books,
it'd be $7.60 times one less
than the number of books you buy.
One way to think about it is
this b minus one, you could think of this
as books you need to pay for.
Books that are not free, I guess.
Books that are not free.
The first book is free,
and every one after that
you would pay for.
And this makes sense.
If b is two.
Two minus one.
You're going to pay for one book.
If b is 10,
that means you're only gonna have to pay
for nine books.
Nine times 7.60 plus the membership.
All right, now let's see
which one of these choices
actually match what we just wrote.
So this one doesn't.
It doesn't include the membership
and doesn't take one from the b
to account for the free book.
This one over here,
it does account for the free book,
but it doesn't account for the membership.
So you don't want to do that.
This one accounts for the membership,
but it doesn't account for the free book.
And then we have this one here,
which is exactly what we wrote,
except they just swapped...
If you just swap these two terms.
If you do $7.60 times b minus one,
plus 60.
So we're gonna go with
that one right there.